all right like the movie The Godfather
The Wizard of Oz often provides life
lessons and parallels to current events
now watch and listen to Jill Biden
closely you know the rapidly rising in
with with I don't know we should be for
example in having a circumstance where
if we have the whole idea of the thing
that the congressman did I need to buy a
vowel okay well aside from the verbal
gaffes and the sentence fragments that
lead to nowhere aren't you reminded of
the Wizard hiding behind that curtain
trying to project a figure of his
strength to the public yet ultimately
failing well lucky for Joe his staff
strictly limits his interview time and
the press then blocks and tackles for
him as he mutters and stumbles along as
you just saw now not only did kovat give
Biden cover to avoid long-form
interviews and in-person events it also
allowed his campaign and other
anti-trump forces to keep distracting us
with false narrative shiny objects and
perpetual fear like watch out a second
wave is coming start shutting everything
down again or the kovat economy will
never ever recover Trump rally attendees
will be super spreaders they're all
selfish they're reckless they're
dangerous and Trump doesn't care about
people's health remember a week earlier
it was WOW those massive BLM protests
are inspiring Trump will refuse to leave
office if he loses and of course the
distraction of the statues and the fight
over all that marble now the new
generals of idiocracy bravely tear down
monuments two old generals of the
Confederacy now one problem these anti
history buffs end up defacing other
monuments of people who actually worked
for the abolitionist movement whoops now
all of this is German
dramatic as it appears at times it's a
complete diversion the new Bolsheviks
hope you'll be so riveted by whatever
spectacle or the pixie dust are thrown
up in the air that you'll forget that
your party is about to nominate someone
who struggles with that whole subject
verb direct object thing look I want one
of the things that that I think is
really important is that we somehow put
that back on
beyond the verbal and cognitive miscues
he's just a Washington dinosaur that
roamed the swamp for what 40 years or so
and yet failed to make any meaningful
structural changes to our supposedly
almost irredeemably corrupt system
so why didn't Obama invite and do big
meaningful initiatives on the issues of
race and policing after Trayvon Martin
and Michael Brown they could have
rallied Congress instead they tossed out
crumbs to satisfy their angry activists
now Obama's a smart guy in his heart of
hearts he has to know that his own
record of policy accomplishments for
inner-city America is kind of scan but
still he's making a guest appearance I
saw to sell the Biden allusion next week
at a virtual fundraiser you have to make
a donation by the way to attend so watch
out now this will be hyped by the media
as if it's Jesus's return to Nazareth
okay but newsflash I hate to break it to
you
Obama won't be president again and with
all the challenges before us we need to
kind of know exactly who will be behind
that Biden screen moving all the levers
Oh Biden can't be the understudy to the
guy who was his for eight years so what
do you do when you don't have a better
economic record than Trump and you're
running against Trump or a better record
on race for that matter
Juneteenth is the oldest celebration of
the end of slavery in the United States
it's time we elevate this July 4 7
seventy-six not everybody was free and
celebrating their Independence Day so
here's our day and if you love us it'll
be your day - all right June teeth teeth
they want that to be a holiday I'd say
just okay fine
but pay no attention to the untold
damage that Northam joconi in lockdown
rules are still doing to businesses and
families especially minority and
immigrant owned and yet he thinks that
he can wipe away all of that with
symbols and celebrities it's just more
distraction now their next trick is to
launch a desperate campaign to cast
president Trump though as the villain
who threatens us all they don't like him
as a person so what they have to do is
deny that he's done anything at all good
for America and of course they need to
call him racist with zero evidence here
was Congressman Jim Clyburn with our own
Bret Baier earlier tonight what about
the first step act for opportun
Opportunity Zones this law came up and
worked with people to get the bill done
and the president signed it but don't
tell me he did it I mean the
administration did it it wasn't the
Obama decision I didn't come here to
argue with you but you can argue it if
you want to but you're not giving the
trouble administration any credit for
the things that Senator Tim Scott has
said it should get credit for absolutely
not because he doesn't deserve it
I mean Bret Baier wasn't trying to pick
a fight with him was doing this thing
called asking a follow-up question but
again pay no attention to Trump's actual
accomplishments the outcomes just ignore
it all instead stick with this twisted
fantasy that President Trump is really
in his heart of hearts wants to work
against people of color some Democrats
go as far as to call the president
racist can you address that from your
perspective you know as a sad state of
affairs but in my
has always been the way to Democrats
play politics I'm against Republicans
all Republicans are racist and rich and
when the truth in the matter is that's
about results he was elected because
people want to see something real and I
just get lied to about politicians and
you could tell today and watching
President Trump that he was extremely
moved by meeting with the families of
men killed by police your loved ones
will not have died in vain we are one
nation we grieve together and we heal
together I can never imagine your pain
or the depth of your anguish but I can
promise to fight for justice for all of
our people and some of the families
seemed moved as well I was very very
emotional throughout the the whole
conference hey well he was very
compassionate he showed major concerns
for all families not just my family
before all families I can say that
President Trump was very receiving he
listened and he addressed each and every
family accordingly now the rest of the
media they won't they won't dwell on
that okay because it doesn't fit their
narrative it was really good for
President Trump to meet with those
families and by the way no cameras in
the room just a chance to listen to them
hear them hear their views on the best
path forward I think we sometimes forget
in the bitterness of today's politics
and I'm sure I'm guilty here that we're
all human you know sometimes we smile
sometimes we weep sometimes we celebrate
sometimes we grieve those families are
grieving President Trump should be
judged by his commitment and his actions
and his results that he's delivering to
all Americans especially the most
disadvantaged and while I realize there
are some who just don't like is
sometimes brash style or sometimes tough
response to critics on Twitter don't let
those style issues distract you with
either it's just completely a waste of
time
this man has risked everything to fight
for American workers while Biden has
basically always carried water for China
and its buddies they
open borders crowd and by the way the
president knows how to make the economy
work for the average American he has and
he will again while Biden was get simply
I'm gonna do whatever the left wants he
can't control a OC or Elon omar or any
of the other radicals and the streets
won't even try
and finally Trump has a realistic
understanding of China and the EU while
the former vice president is ludicrously
naive about both how hard is it to
imagine Biden doing his own version of
Obama's post bush 2009 apology tour and
while joe is busy apologizing China and
the EU will clean his an hour clock now
just like Dorothy and Friends Americans
will be disappointed as it becomes
apparent that Biden behind that curtain
won't make their wishes come true
he's just the Wizard of Oz and that's
the angle